[Music]
Abby Lee Miller that is still in the
hospital yes yes have you been in
contact with her we have we actually
were just talking to her a couple days
ago she obviously is not well she's not
good she's not great she's not healed
but she is on the right track she's not
what hard percent there yet but she is
doing good she's going through therapy
she's going through all the things right
now that she needs me going through
chemo obviously I think she only has
like one or two more rounds of chemo so
that's really really good for her but
she's happy she's in good spirits we she
has big plans coming up with Dance Moms
and her studio on the west coast so
she's big things coming up that I'm
really excited for her together do you
like feel bad like that you didn't like
get to see my solo you mentioned that
she is gonna be part of the new Dance
Moms we have learned recently how do you
think that cancer has changed her I
think what's gonna happen is she's going
to be able to enjoy life more and
realize that it is just dance and we
should be dancing for her purpose but at
the same time I'm like a zombie she's
still got she's gonna come out of this
she's gonna beat it she's going to go
back and do it and she is going to be as
awesome as she could possibly be and
she's going to be better than ever and
she's gonna be strong and powerful and
she's just gonna come out on top of it
and they've been filming her so people
would dance on season eight they'll get
to see kind of what's actually going on
right now
oh there's cameras in they didn't notice
a little bit of her yeah yeah I know
that on Instagram but then I asked and
that is true she's there fill in a
little bit well I know that you made me
emotional a lot of people emotional when
you showed up and you brought that to
her what I'm sure touched her not beyond
and I don't know if I mentioned this in
the video because I know that I wanted
her to kind of a personal moment but
there's a first of all dancers and
cancer is an amazing organization so the
fact that they were able to give her
this check of ten grand was unbelievable
to help her she has a medical cost order
to go out and get some TCBY like
whatever she needs it for just to have
money for her which is so nice of them
have you actually had no idea that we're
doing the check she had no idea of
nothing any chance that we're gonna see
make an appearance on your show I'm not
gonna be all lip-sync battle beyond the
jojomo show show but we do she wants to
be on the judge his juice my youtube
series she's got to get herself well
she's got to focus on herself focus on
her health focus on her physical and
mental health honestly and then when
she's good to go await you in my camera
I'm ready for it I think before you
juice on our head would be amazing
[Music]